hello everyone how's everyone doing
today I hope just as good as me I'm
doing okay today we'll be moving right
along I'll be discussing again well we
discussed the other day I'm going to
continue with what we were doing in
other words I'm going to be analyzing
the debate I had with this fellow named
Peter no name no last name just Peter
he's a mathematical physicist he came
over to question challenge the rope
model and I kind of steered them over a
little bit into what physics is about in
other words the foundations of physics
and I think we need to get the
foundation straight first before we can
do any higher level physics we need to
double check our kindergarten stuff
before we go to college okay
and the problem right now is
kindergarten stuff mathematical physics
doesn't meet the minimum criteria the
minimum spec for what is physics and
that's the issue that's the issue that
I'm trying to make people aware of we
have to go back and find out what is
physics and even before that what is
science and what I'm saying is
essentially in a nutshell that for the
last 400 years the mathematicians have
taken over just developed this way it's
not a conspiracy or anything like that
just the way things evolved and turns
out that the inheritors of of science of
physics have been the mathematicians and
so they self-serving ly converted
physics into math and math into physics
signs into math and math into science
and that's the issue the issue is that
we're not doing science anymore and
you're saying
is that right I mean haven't done sighs
look at the progress we've made look at
all the technology you have science
can't be that wrong and yeah science is
wrong because we're not talking about
technology technology is fine and we
developed that by trial and error so
it's got nothing to do with science
science is about explaining a phenomenon
rationally and we don't have that today
we don't have a single rational
explanation from the mathematical
establishment for all those phenomena
which are mediated by invisible entities
light gravity magnetism the workings of
the atom electricity none of those can
be explained today they cannot give you
an explanation where they use objects
specifically where you can visualize
what's going on and so they that's when
they go back to spirits we're back to
the Dark Ages they they do it with
spirits and they call these spirits with
different names and they all have these
scientific sounding names but their
spirits make no you know no poems about
it it's it's spirits okay so what were
the problems that I found with mr. Peter
he went by a name of Peter I the first
one is that unanimity I covered that and
then and the second one didn't
understand the golden principle of
physics that's about as much as I got to
cover the other day let me just say the
following as far as I know enemity is
concerned all it shows is that there is
an environment of fear there's no reason
for Peter to remain in hiding you know
in secret why would be what would be the
reason for him to avoid you know coming
out and saying look I'm Peter and I'm a
physicist and I challenged the rope
bottle fine but he didn't do that he
kind of didn't want to be known out
there maybe his colleagues might think
terribly of him
he's debating someone who disagrees with
mathematical physics doesn't agree with
the foundations of quantum mechanics or
relativity or string theory and and yeah
people are afraid for their jobs and so
I think that's the main reason you know
he didn't want to be embarrassed in
front of his colleagues or whatever who
knows but there I think there's an
environment of fear and it also shows in
what is published what is allowed to be
published and what is allowed to reach
the public and what you will not see
reaching the public are opposition's to
quantum or relativity and so they
constantly claim you know it's never
been falsified you read that everywhere
you know you read it in papers you read
it in the Wikipedia you read it all over
the place that you know quantum has
never been falsified relativity has
never been falsified people say oh so
they're sound theories well yeah they've
never been falsified because you're not
allowed to criticize these theories even
call them that you're not allowed to
criticize them from a qualitative point
of view you're not something you cannot
say that they're irrational in fact
don't beat you to it they'll say oh we
know it's irrational nobody understands
it so how can you say that it's been
proven how how can you say that these
theories you know are ground in stone
and they're not referring to the
physical interpretation they'd only look
at the quantitative stuff and they also
look at what they observed or so-called
observed in the lab so they see
something in the lab they interpret it
for you making a assumptions
specifically the assumptions that
everything is mediated by particles and
that's all you'll ever hear and now they
won't allow you to come up with an
alternative to that and yeah that
creates some problems out there because
when you try to challenge it on from a
rational point
you they agree with you and they say
yeah we don't care about that we know we
can't understand it we've proven it but
we can't understand it so they're saying
is you know we saw something in the lab
we interpreted in terms of particles it
doesn't make sense to us but look at the
equations and look at the technology
we've developed that's the argument
that's the argument they have that's
there is no other argument okay so what
are the problem with Peter well Peter
sent some four articles to me these were
the four articles the first one had to
do with the slit experiment I'm sorry
yeah the slit experiment because
essentially it's Tana Maura's he's a
Japanese researcher and Tana more in his
group did the slit experiment with
electrons and electricity essentially
and he claims he handled one electron at
a time the second one is a three slit
experiment with three slits the third
one is compton scattering and last one
is the electron positron annihilation
experiments done by organization known
as LEP luck okay these were the papers
that he sent me he's saying a debunk or
in his opinion I have no way of
explaining that with a rope model okay
and so that was his argument is the way
he came into the debate and the problem
of the four papers is that you know none
of them had objects in them thank you
won't see a single picture of any object
that mediates any of the phenomena that
these people analyzed here so what is
the problem the problem is that we have
no objects and let's go with the first
one here's tiny more I'm just gonna go
briefly through them because I've
covered that in the previous lecture but
let's go quickly through them what's
wrong with them here's Tana Maura's
single electron
how he handled each one but the problem
is he says look at that second line the
relative phase shift was measured
between two electron waves two electron
waves and then later on he says when the
magnetic field was confined right at the
bottom there the magnetic field was
confined so he can find out a magnetic
field and he talked about passing
electron waves through I guess the slits
right well uh we got a problem with that
first because Tanimura wrote a paper a
long time ago see if I can see it here
give me a second here and he wrote a
paper in what is it 1989 - one at the
bottom says Tana Mora there his group
demonstration of single electron buildup
okay so ton of ore has been been doing
slit experiment for quite a while he's
doing it with electrons and in this case
he did it with single electron but in
his current paper the one I was sent by
Peter he talks about passing electron
waves
well yeah it's this old duality between
wave and particle is an electron a wave
or is it a particle well they tell us
both whenever it's convenient for the
mathematician that he convert the part
of going to a wave and whether they want
to explain another aspect of their
experiment they'll convert it back into
a particle and that's the problem
the problem is that you know the
electron is this malleable ghost turns
into a leprechaun when he hides his gold
when you try to catch him he turns into
a spirit he fizzles out of your hands
and that's how the electron broke and
you say well is that that's irrational
how can the electron spontaneously for
no reason whatsoever by what mechanism
you know convert from a particle to a
wave and wave to a particle wave is is
an elongated spread-out kind of thing
and the party was like a concentrated
point you know it's a condensed a piece
of matter they're you know a little dot
and you know these are two conflicting
notions of what a thing is supposed to
be is the electron a ball tiny ball or
is it a way is it an ocean bunch of
waves which is it and they say it's both
and that's the problem the problem is
that until we can figure out you know
what an electron is looks like we can't
say that Oh an electron hit the wall
because again he suggested Peter
suggested that well you know it's like
we noticed that there was a something
happening at the wall like a single hit
and what else could it be you know and I
showed what else it should be the other
day let's continue here well maybe I
should show that give me a second here
so I can find this right here at the
bottom here's uh here's the way these
folks do it
quantum they do it with cannons
you know they trouble paint cannonballs
up the walls to make holes in them this
is their notion of how what how an
electron is shot and how an electron
hits the wall and makes a hole
okay so holes are made with cannons and
cannonballs these people are still in
the 19th century well how do we do it in
the 21st century well we do it a little
differently we do it with oh here it is
with a drill bit we drill holes we don't
shoot cannonballs at the wall we do it
with a drill bit and the drill bit you
know twirls around and makes a hole in
the wall never occurred to them that
electricity could be a drill bit like a
drill bit and here is electricity as I
always point out let me make it
bigger so you can see it electricity is
a whole bunch of electron shells and
here's a simple picture of it in other
words here we're using hydrogen atoms
the simplest S orbital that's it
obviously it's a lot more complicated
than this but here we can see the
essence of it all these shells are
interconnected they form what I call a
serpentine that serpentine throws in
place and what you have is electricity
going into your face there and what's
going at 90 degrees is the field of
magnetic field which is at 90 degrees to
electricity which is what's going in
your direction and so this is a new
notion we're saying that's what
electricity is and obviously that fits
in with the drill bit drilling in place
that's what we're saying that's how the
holes are being made you need to have a
like that you need to have atoms in
order to have electricity without atoms
there is no electricity there is no
electricity in empty space going from
one galaxy to another like the electric
universe for example maintains you need
atoms to do that and the problem is that
all these people the quantum people in
the electric universe people which is
just a sect of quantum they believe that
you know electricity consists of a bunch
of beads that travel through space like
a flow of beads and so if anything in a
vacuum electricity should travel much
easier because the mean free path is
increased I mean if you remove all the
matter that's just think of this you're
gonna remove every atom okay and so now
there's no obstacle so now all these
beads all these electron beads taken out
of their atoms right we've got all these
electron beads me remove them we've
ionized every atom now we got all these
loose beads they form a flow of beads
right they're moving along
you shoot him with a gun or whatever
like mr. dr. quantum did you know I'm
gonna show that in a second also he
throws them you're not something at a
wall and there's no atoms in between the
gun and the wall no atoms litter so
there's no obstacle these electron beats
it flow like you know like honey
no problem there is nothing stopping
them and that's not the case that's not
the case you need atoms to have a flow
of electricity and they never learn this
the more you pump down a chamber pump it
down to minus 2 or 7th or minus 8 tor -
12 tor you have minus 11 on on the moon
they also measured minus 11 range in
outer space in interplanetary space they
had a think it was a Apollo 14 or 15
they in the back you know they opened up
the the trunk and they had a little
machine that read the vacuum level of
space as the probe was as the Apollo was
going to the moon so in the middle of
space between the Earth and the moon
they measured the vacuum and it was in
the minus 11 range that's what they also
measured on the moon so we're pretty
comfortable that in in interplanetary
space when you don't get too close to a
planet like you know Jupiter has got a
lot of gases and so on you don't get too
close like you turn about between two
planets you're gonna have maybe - 11 -
12 range - 11 - 12
tor okay just because there are
different measures as Pascal's and so on
talking about tor so you know you're
gonna have - eleven - twelve tor that's
high vacuum very high vacuum there is no
electricity in -11 tour and even though
there's gazillions of particles in there
I mean you have like five hundred and
three hundred thousand particles I think
per cubic meter so there's still a whole
bunch of particles there in a - eel oven
so keep that in mind there's still a
whole bunch of particles in there I'm
not sure how many thousands I have to
look it up but I know there are
thousands of particle
per cubic meter even so in that
low-density region you cannot have very
much current and in fact he Peter he
suggested that in a high vacuum I think
he worked in a minus seven range they
could shoot like one electron every
twenty seconds yeah I don't doubt that I
mean I don't think you can have a
current with with high vacuum you want
to have current you need to put
something in there
in fact in at AMD we used to put you
know we pump the chamber down to minus
seven then fill it with argon ionized
the argon and use the ion the argon ion
is bullets and we shot him against an
aluminum target or titanium titanium
nitride depending on where we were
sputtering and it acts like a machine
gun you know all these uh ions just hit
the target and chip off pieces which
fall under wafer and they give you a
nice coating of the wafer but you need
to have you need to have some something
in there in order to have electricity
okay and they never figured that out
they think it's a question-- shooting
bullets through through the vacuum and
that's not the case and so yeah it's a
different way of doing y'all electricity
it's a drill bit anyways
Tana Morra had that problem the other
problem now Tana Mora had is that he
mentions the word field and this is a
field that's what a field is you've got
three types of field there you got an
electric field magnetic field and
gravitational field and the ones on the
bottom are the same things but without
that little dot in the center without
some matter because that's what quantum
claims that a field is that it you can
have a field without matter without an
object okay so the ones on the bottom
have no objects in them okay and so you
say well what are those arrows well
those are you know these are vectors
that's all they are they have magnitude
and direction so you have a bunch of
magnitudes and directions and that's a
field in fact we don't have to kill our
brains here we'll let
mathematical physicists tell you what a
field is here we have mr. John Carroll
he gave a presentation and think it was
in Cambridge particle at the end of the
universe 2013 he says instead of
thinking about random forces between
objects very very far away imagine
there's a field filling the universe
booth and what that means mathematically
is that at every point in space there's
a number there you have a definition of
a field what he means by field and every
point in space there's a number the
value of the field just like the
temperature of the air in this room at
every point there is a value the
temperature at that point of the air
look at the bottom down last paragraph
the field is what the world is made of
particles are what you see so the atom
in this table the electrons the quarks
the protons these are all vibrations in
fields there's a quark field that is
vibrating and you look at it and you see
quarks there's an electron field that is
vibrating there's a neutrino field that
is vibrating there's a gravitational
field that is vibrating and so on and so
on okay so he defines it as a every
point in space there's a number and now
he's saying that these numbers are
vibrating in other words the field the
entire field is vibrating and that's
what a particle is so we associate
particle with the vibration of the field
well here you'll see it for the first
time in your life keep in mind you you
can say that you saw it here first okay
and here it is here's the field you ever
wanted to see a field here I have a
field for you that's a field bunch of
vibrating numbers values quantities
amounts and as you can see the numbers
get bigger towards the center and as you
get away from the center the numbers hit
smaller that's a field and they're
vibrating so what you're staring at is a
particle the particle is a vibration of
the field and what is a field a bunch of
numbers so this is what these people are
saying
and this is not a semantic issue no it's
not it's it goes to the heart of what
these people are saying they're saying a
particle is a vibration of a field and
what is a field it's a bunch of numbers
so there you have it that's exactly what
they're saying so this is not semantics
this is what they're saying is their
field and what they're saying is their
particle so whenever they talk about
particles you have no idea what they're
talking about because they're not
talking about a corpuscle okay they're
talking about a vibrating field
okay so Tana Mora fails on all counts
Tana Mora says look first we're dealing
with fields what's a field field is just
a bunch of numbers second we're dealing
with waves and but wave is what passes
through the slits what we detect is a
cannonball you know on the wall on a
screen or wherever he did or at the
detector wherever he senses us right so
how much weight should you put on
tomorrow's paper none absolutely none
because it's on an unscientific paper
and again they won't allow people like
me to review his paper and show him that
you know we're all his errors are you
know it's reviewed by his colleague
people who give each other Nobel Prizes
you know and so they all are the same
Club and they all vouch for each other
and they're the ones who control the
reigns of editing of editorial space for
the big magazines of big journals and
someone in a popularization magazine who
usually is also a mathematician he
translates that for the public and
that's that's the way it works today so
you will not see criticism of quantum or
relativity out there in the mainstream
okay okay the second paper was about
superposition and this is word that's
about paper said exotic loops
trajectories of photons and three slit
interference what's the problem here the
problem is first the fact that they're
talking about predictions I talked a
little bit about that the other day
they're predicting the path
but whenever they use the word
prediction they really mean explanation
okay that's what they're saying and but
the point here was that they're talking
about observing whether they observe or
measure they measure excitations of
plasmas and of fields near fields in the
vicinity of slits through the
excitations of surface plasmas we just
covered the field what's a plasma look
at the bottom says a plasma is a an
amount a quantity of plasma oscillation
and what's a plasma oscillation rapid
oscillations of the electron density
what's an electron it's a field of a
vibrating field so we got all these
circular arguments where with just one
concept underlying another concept there
is no physical object in all of quantum
them let alone in all of mathematical
physics okay and so here is their this
is what they put in quantum optics which
is more or less a publication for the
public okay and the issue here was that
the first two lines here that are
underlined you see prize on offer
disproving the principle of
superposition with which they would
destroy quantum mechanics what they're
singing here is in an S then the next
line there to investigate whether
superposition really occurs in nature is
this what science is about about just
verifying that superposition occurs in
nature and if it does does that prove
quantum mechanics is that the issue I
mean what they need to do is explain
superposition if they're just gonna go
out there and say look you know we
verified one more time that
superposition occurs does that ratify
quantum mechanics now it just ratifies
that they're still ignorant it's they
can't tell you why superposition occurs
or by what mechanism occurs and let me
tell you what superposition is here
which is what I did
the other day here you have dr. quantum
and he's gonna shoot bullets and let's
see when it starts here again give it a
second here we're gonna see him crying
because he can't figure it out okay and
what's the problem the problem is these
folks do it everything with particles
he's got his marble machine he's gonna
shoot particles through the single slit
and obviously he's gonna get us in goal
line when he shoots through two you
should expect to see two lines but
instead always read particles you see
many lines so he tries one particle at a
time with his single beam shooter the
problem is here that the particle is out
two places at once and then recombines
on the screen okay so what are they
saying they say they have this
decoherence and superposition nonsense
they say that a particle can well here I
have it Illustrated so why explain it
when we have it Illustrated a particle
can be at two places at once and it also
can have two states and it can be bright
vibrating and at the same time it cannot
be vibrating and when you try to check
one state it immediately converts into
one or the other so this is what they
have they have an excited atom and a
nine excited atom at the same time and
they have one add a one particle
occupied to different locations at the
same time and they call this the
coherence and superposition okay so so
this is where we're at today this is an
in a claimed as a science and so the
question is you know when you criticize
this and say on a qualitative basis they
say well we know we can't understand it
either so so you're wasting your time
here you're attacking a straw man here
what you got to do is go to the lab and
verify that superposition and
decoherence happen in other words their
interpretation of it and second look at
our math and see it's all correct we've
got it all covered with equations and we
do develop technology so everything is
fine and we never get
a an interpretation of physical
interpretation and explanation for
what's going on and they say well you
know we don't understand it either of
course you don't understand it because
if you applied popper your own popper
you know they do agree with popper
called popper and he said that you know
if an experiment falsifies your theory
you should reject the theory what they
did instead of rejecting quantum
mechanics because all experiment 150
percent of them falsify the particle
hypothesis what they said is look
whenever you know we falsify the
particle hypothesis we just convert it
into a way when we continue rogen so
they have this duality and they still
keep quantum they're not going to reject
quantum
that's what's happening and of course
you won't find a single wave in the
standard model all you will find is the
particles up there
I think there's 13 of them primary ones
there's over 200 that they found so far
they have invented so far and you won't
find a wave and the other thing you
won't find is a picture of any of the
particles they've never seen a particle
they're assuming that they're dealing
with particles and so here we have the
fourth paper where is it here yes is
this the fourth no this is the third
month sorry this is x-ray compton
scattering okay and what are they
talking about here again no part no no
objects all we're talking about single
particle excitations you know the Beach
Boys used to call it good vibrations
these call it these guys call it
excitations okay
two identical photons convert into a
single photon and what's a photon it's a
vibrating field so so we're done you
know I mean we don't have any objects
and I'm not gonna go through it in more
detail than that all I'm gonna say is
here you see what they're added to
towards this is and here's a comment by
this physicist I guess mathematical
physicists she says we know that our
press
theories are correct a high-precision
and new theories cannot differ by much
or they are false already okay and again
they talk about interactions between
raise the claim day they observe the
process they observe something that's
visible and they infer what's invisible
and they convert the two photons into a
single photon you can take as much as
you want from that you know they cannot
explain what they did all they do is
describe and they say yeah we this is
what we observed and so it confirms
quantum mechanics what does it confirm
and you don't have an explanation it
doesn't confirm an explanation just
confirms that you observe something
you're describing it in terms of
particles and you call that confirmation
of quantum because you're confirming
your assumption that's what they're
doing and here's the last one where is
it here here's the paper where we have
the what is it the electron and positron
annihilation all they did was do
measurements this this report was only
about measurements but these
measurements supposedly confirm that
there are electrons there are positrons
a positron is a negative electron when
it meets a negative electron what
happens well at that point they
annihilate and what's the problem with
that well the problem with that again is
that you're assuming that an electron
and a positron are particles we don't
know what they look like or why they are
so different so opposite and why because
why they when they combine they end up
annihilating turning into nothing I
guess just energy you know and so the
question is whether they're dealing with
particles when they visualize these
experiments in other words they observe
something visible and in their chambers
and then they interpret they interpret
and they say well what we think we saw
what we know we saw were particles one
is the electron the other one the
positron one has a negative sign on its
back the other one has a positive sign
and when they meet they annihilate
turn into nothing or energy or whatever
they turn into a concept and what's the
problem with that well the problem comes
with mr. Andersson Karl Anderson a long
time ago 1932 he came up with a
suppository he called it the positron I
call it the suppository
not because it's a suppository but
because he supposed he supposed that he
was doing he was dealing with particles
and this is what he saw he saw a little
line that curved line that you see on
the left and he saw that on his chamber
and at language right through the bar
there that's a lead bar that you see
across the field of view there and when
you look at it in detail you see that
there are missing you know it it kind of
jumps that's what I'm saying you know
the particle just went up and down and
made these holes in there these little
grooves because in between the grooves
you can see that there's a little bit of
space there where it's not very deep
so suddenly it's deep and suddenly it's
not and I'm saying that's more more like
a drill bit again you know the drill
been twirling in place could leave a
pattern like that otherwise the particle
would have to jump up and down like a
jumping bean and in order to create that
kind of pattern and so I'm saying that
what Carl Anderson found was not a
particle first of all and if that's the
case he's got to return his Nobel medals
okay it was a little premature to give
him one okay so in summary right what we
have here is that none of the papers
that Peter gave me have particles in
them they're all done with concepts and
none of those concepts are valid in
physics and if they're not valid in
physics none of those papers are
scientific and we should should all
think in those terms these are not
scientific papers they're not scientific
paper because science is 150 percent
qualitative we don't deal with
quantities quantities only describe
science is about
baby you have to explain how the
magician did the trick not what he did
you can't say yeah he kept the lady in
half he'd used 20 strokes as a saw and
he did it in ten seconds that's that you
know describing describing how fast the
lion runs you know thirty miles per hour
is that science is science saying oh the
elephant weighed you know two tonnes is
it science about saying the dog ran
somebody so much distance in so many
seconds is that science no science is
explaining something explaining a
mechanism that's where you have to use
your head but measuring and say oh we
were able to measure this too high
degree of accuracy like you know in fact
they brought up I think it was jfg he he
brought up the issue that you know
Einstein's equation one of the reasons
it was successful in nineteen and
fifteen later on in 1919 confirmed by
Cavendish oh but the point is that you
know the fact that Einstein's equation
was more accurate than Newton's so what
what's that got to do with anything
you got to look at the explanation that
Einstein gave for gravity and that's you
know that you're bending space-time
that's his explanation that's its
physical interpretation that's all we
care about we don't care about his
equation we don't care if he had a
nightmare the previous night we don't
care where he got it we care about what
he comes up with and says look I'm gonna
explain to you what gravity is what the
mechanism is okay what is it Einstein
and he says well you know it's the
warping of space-time
what is space-time can you draw a
picture of it so we know what you wore
he says no I cannot imagine space-time
Oh
why not because it's four-dimensional Oh
so how do you not exist or how do you
know there is something out there called
space-time in fact how can there
possibly be something called space-time
in space is nothing it's a there's not
nothing called space it's total vacuum
that's what space is it's nothing it's a
synonym of nothing and then you have
time which is obviously a concept and
you can't take nothing plus time and
create a four-dimensional object so you
cannot say you worked nothing plus time
but assuming space is something okay so
you get a rock and we'll call that space
you got rock if you unite it with time
what do you have you have rock time a
four-dimensional Rock time is that what
you warped so it's absolutely it's
absolute nonsense what these people are
saying they're bending concepts
unimaginable concepts undefined concepts
and that's why you know the Einstein's
explanation from gravity is bogus and
that's what we got to look at not the
fact that his equation is more accurate
than Newton's who cares about that in
fact they use Newton every day they
don't use Einstein the people at NASA
date when they send rockets into space
they only only only use Newton they
never use Einstein's equal equation it's
worthless for him and let me tell you
why there's another reason for that now
why Einstein you can clean your butwith
with Einstein's equations worthless I
Stein says this is what his field
equation says essentially it's a point
mass that's going around see he wanted
to figure out why Mercury's perihelion
you know you know he went to calculate
that orbit he said look there's a little
bit of difference between Newton's
equation and what we actually observed
there's a difference there and he says
oh I know I've got an equation that I
can explain that or justify it and what
he did is he took a point totally
different notion Newton said look you
got a mass over here you got another
mass over here
they're separated by a distance the
closer they are together the higher the
force the farther away they are you know
the the lower the force in other words
distance the greater the distance the
lower the force and vice versa
okay so force and distance are inversely
related
that's essentially what Newton said I
said says something totally different he
says look you take a point mass and I
can describe the itinerary of that point
mass around the Sun so it's a totally
different notion than two masses
separated by by distance that's the
difference between Newton and Einstein
so Einstein's equation is more accurate
because he talked about something else
you're talking about an itinerary of a
point mass so what okay so it's more
accurate who gives a damn I mean tell me
why why this thing this planet in this
case mercury it doesn't fly out of the
solar system so he says I know I can
tell you that what this equation really
tells us is not really the itinerary of
a point mass it's telling you the
curvature of space around the Sun it
tells you the shape of the bowl okay
telling you the shape of the bowl that
the mass of the Sun is creating around
itself that's that's the notion that
we're talking about here so he's telling
you the shape of the bowl and that's
different than mass times mass divided
by distance squared that Newton hat and
so what happened when you when you get
to that point you say okay but what is
this bowl and that's where space-time
comes in and he says well it's
space-time and Senator Manchin will try
to imagine it we took space plus time
but when you look deep inside it all
they're talking about is four
coordinates really four number lines to
locate a point in space so that's it's
you know that's the field equation the
field equation just tells you
essentially that you need four
coordinates to locate a point within
spacetime they turn that around and said
space-time is a physical
you bend it down and you create this
bowl and that's why mercury has no other
option but to roll around the you know
like the room the ball around the
roulette that's it that's in a nutshell
what we're talking about okay okay so
it's gone with with the next topic here
the other problem we had with Peter was
objects and I started out with a golden
principle okay see if I can get these
things up here here's the golden
principle that I showed him and I said
look you know I want to see if you agree
with this but essentially I said I came
up with the golden principle physics and
that's like the number one step in
physics you need to establish some
guidelines this is the first guideline
physics requires an object you can't do
physics without an object and what I'm
saying here is if God removes all matter
from the universe what is happening what
phenomenon is is occurring what are you
watching what are you imagining if
there's nothing there so you need an
object to do physics so what did he say
you're probably right and that's
incredible because this is not a
question of probably it's a question of
yes no and a physicist should always say
yes and if he's got doubts about that
well we got a big problem I don't know
what you know it just gives you an idea
of what he learned in college how can he
say that I'm probably right no I'm not
probably right you're you should be
guessing this you should know and like
you know there's there's nothing to
discuss here it's not negotiable
I it's not that I'm right it's that you
can't do physics without an object
there's nothing happening it's just a
conceptual issue and he says you do need
an object but then again he never you
know use an object in his whole
discussion in the entire debate and not
specifically in none of the papers that
he submitted okay and here's a proof
let's provide proof peter insinuates
that the concept for the space-time is a
fabric okay and again he he brought that
word fabric in there which
mathematical physics like to you know
bring into the discussion and I'm saying
there's only three D from here to
eternity year to God's heaven there's no
to Dean or one D no zero D or four D and
Peter says to that I would disagree so
he what's insist because obviously if
you know there is no such thing as 4d
where does that leave where does that
leave you know all of mathematical
physics officially general relativity if
there is no such thing as 4d there's no
such thing as space-time there's no such
thing as spacetime Janet wrote there he
goes down the drain if there's no such
thing as zero D singularity
that's the end of the black holes so
there's no black holes either and little
by little T destroyed all of
mathematical physics if you get rid of
the zero these into four T's if you only
stick to three DS and really physics
only studies 3d what exists only three D
can exist there's no 2d there's no zero
D no one be no 4011 D 2060s
bring it about all that okay so what
does he say he says well you know he
says the following he says I said what
is an object Peter says your point is
that it has to have size absolutely not
that thought my point but he continues
we don't know what that the size of some
particles is particle is a linguistic
shorthand no kiddin you know particle is
not a particle is a vibration of a field
so it's got to be a shorthand they have
to they have to kind of hide the real
notion of what a particle is because a
lot of people otherwise would question
it sitting that it has shape that's a
little bit uncertain he tells me that he
agrees that there and we can't do things
without an object there's no physics
without an object and now he says well
we have this particle and he's gonna say
that another turn as a particle later on
and he says but he doesn't know whether
it has shape it's got sighs maybe he
says I don't know yeah it could be
but he's uncertain with her it has shape
so I have no idea what he's talking
about you know how can how can a
particle not have shape and that's why
he says I'm a little uncertain
we have precision tests to determine
what is the shape of the electron we
don't know yet we don't know the
electron size other particles are
produced when we probe it let me tell
you what the problem is the the
criterion is not size its shape shape is
not size size in that shape size you
need another object to compare it
against okay you can't have size unless
you have a ruler you can't have size on
this you have you know the elephant
compared against the lion then you can
say yeah one guy has a bigger size than
the other you can only talk about sizes
there's another object to compare it
against could be a ruler it could be
another object doesn't matter but you
gotta connect sizes comparison that's
not what shape is shape is and we're not
asking what is the shape of the electron
we're saying the electron had better
half shape we don't care what its shape
is it could be a blob for all we care
could be a sphere it can be a Pew we
don't care we're saying that if you're
gonna talk about intellect I'm you're
gonna introduce it into physics it had
better have shape that's what we're
saying we're not saying that energy has
this shape or that shape we're not
saying air has this shape or that shape
we're not saying that an ocean has this
shape or that's it we're saying it had
better have shape so you can take a
balloon with air in it and that air has
a spherical shape that air now you put
it around the earth now that air has a
shell shape it's like a shell covering
the earth so you can have different
shapes of air but but air had better
have shame if the astronaut takes a
balloon into new space pops it in the
middle of nowhere that blob if we can
see it made it's an irregular blob it's
not spiritual it's not shell shaped just
uh it's just a blob they're irregular
shaped thing that's just floating in air
may be expanding that blob that whole
thing has shape we don't care what shape
it is you can
say well it has shape here but it's
changing its shape we don't care about
that it had better have shape there has
to be limits to that thing that's Road
Ian's in space because it's made out of
atoms it had better have shape you can't
say it does not have shape you can say
that you don't know what the shape of
air is inside the balloon inside over
the earth or out there as a blob in
space you can say you don't know what
the shape of air is but air has shape
it's a yes or no type of question now
that question of which shape does it
have and the electron same thing we
don't care what its shape is it had
better have shape if it wants to be a
part of physics and this fella says he
doesn't know whether it has shape and
that we're trying to measure the size
but we can't measure the size we don't
care about all that we don't give a damn
about any of that it's got nothing to do
it's a conceptual issue and electron had
better have shame and and it's up to the
proponent to tell us what shape it has
or whether it has shape he's got a draw
he says for the purposes of my theory
this is the shape I'm gonna I'm gonna
give the electron we don't care what the
real electron in the real life has we
don't care about that and let me tell
you why if the guy's gonna explain look
how is the electron attached to the atom
to the nucleus well it's hook shaped
then you can say okay I understand how
how the nucleus maintains the electron
tied to you to it you know faithful to
it because they're both hook shaped and
this one is hooked up to that one that's
why the shape would be important there
because you could say okay I can see
that or maybe there's an elastic you
know between them and you can say well
you know the electron stretches all the
way to the nucleus through an elastic or
a spring or a wire or whatever tether
and you can say okay now I understand
why the electron doesn't fly away
because you can see the shape of it you
know it's physical shape because the guy
drew it he says this what I'm gonna
assume for the purpose of my theory fine
then you can follow his theory
but if the Electra's floating out there
in the middle of nowhere and you say
what keeps it tied to the proton what
eats it tied to the nucleus and the guy
has no answer like Peter did not have an
answer here were his answers he he this
was his I'm getting ahead of myself but
no problem here here's what he said
essentially we had this dialogue and he
goes something like this here he says
Peter we know that there is an electron
that exists at a single point in space
if we know C he knows it's you can't
challenge this there's a an electron
that exists at a single point I can
detect a particle in a location so we
can say with a high degree of accuracy
that it is particle like so he's basing
it on something he never saw he just
says we see something that's particle
like so we're gonna call it a particle
okay but before you can tell me about
that you got to draw your your atom you
got to show me how the electron fits
into your atom to make sure that you
know it is a particle that it can be a
particle and so when physical entity
keeps the electron tied to the nucleus
that's the question the mathematics
points to photons and those photons are
considered virtual so he's saying that
photons discrete photons maintain the
electron tied to the nucleus by what by
magic I mean if I have a bunch of
particles like you know balls why would
they keep a bowling ball tied to to a
basketball for example well what does
the fact that you have all these are
like all these virtual photons in there
how does that keep another ball tied to
another ball so he has not answered the
question he has not told us the
mechanism and anyways he introduces the
virtual particle okay if you want a
physical interpretation you can talk
about an electromagnetic potential again
potential is not a physical object like
a potential space time again I'm not a
physical object we can talk about a
fabric which spends electrons moving
forward and away from the electrons so
he's talking about
fabric what is it what kind of fabric is
he talking about well here it is he he
kind of illustrated that he gets this
one let's see well here he showed his
electron tied to the nucleus again
that's his notion of the atom okay and
again that that's the standard planetary
model that has already been debunked so
the question is what does what keeps the
electron bound to the nucleus and he he
essentially illustrates it like this on
camera he shows a ball right and he puts
it inside a rag he puts it inside this
cloth and he says kind of embedded in
there and that's what keeps it there and
you can see on the right-hand side there
he drew all those lines he's saying
that's like the rag there so I made a
little better picture there so we know
what what he's really talking about here
he calls it the fabric okay so as you
can imagine here's the rag and you put
electron beads you can put one you can
put several eggs in there if you want in
that basket no problem and since it's a
two-dimensional type of scenario where
the ball pushes the rag downwards and
that's why it's stuck out there in the
periphery of the atom I drew the little
rag there on the left-hand side on the
bottom picture and you can see it why it
doesn't fall towards the center and why
it doesn't fly away because it's stuck
in this in this depression okay well he
knew that that's a 2-dimensional
scenario and so he quickly changed his
tune and said well it's more like a
flute you got to think of it like a
fluid and to make matters worse yet it's
it's a like an ether theory which has
also been debunked by the way so I said
well what kind of rag is this what kind
of fabric is this he says it's a
potential what do you mean
but their potentials is a concept he
said would you know what voltage is yeah
I know what voltage is well it's like a
voltage
well voltage is also a concept and so is
a space fabric and potential and right
all these all these are just you know
just words that he's using in there not
one of them qualifies as a physical
object especially if you're gonna I mean
a rally is a physical object obviously
but if you're going to equate it to a
potential then it's not and if you're
gonna say that uh you get a fabric and
say what's a fabric what's a voltage
well voltage is not a physical object or
if it's a potential it's not a physical
object so what is he talking about these
are all kind of a concept so this is
essentially what he's saying here here's
another picture he's saying you got a
ball and that ball is in caught in some
kind of undulation
it's you've got all these car carbonated
carpet maybe or think of it any way you
want a rag and it's kind of stuck in
there but see this is a two-dimensional
scenario and he realizes that so he said
well you know you don't really have to
think about this as a fluid so now he
brings his his fishtank analogy now you
have all this fluid all the fishies are
flying around in there right and he puts
the ball the electron ball in that fluid
in this three dimensional fluid that
surrounds an atom but what's the problem
is that you know those fishies are not
attracted to to the center of the atom
neither is the ball because a fluid has
no ability to attract so again he has
not answered the question by turning his
rag into a fluid okay no way that you
can explain that you can justify that
you can give me a mechanism for why the
electron doesn't find a way by using
either rag or fluid and so he just keeps
eluding issue because he doesn't like to
deal with these issues he just wants to
show me that the elect
hit that he got on the wall or on his
detector that's a single electron hit
and he doesn't want to deal with this
part which is what does the atom that
shot that electron look like before you
shoot the electron show me your atom so
that I can understand your atom and of
course he doesn't want to do that he
doesn't want to deal with that and so
you know we get down to what is an
object and an object is that which has
shape and this is what an object is not
an object is not that which you can see
it's not that what you can touch not
that which you have that has size or
radius or diameter it's not that which
can move it's that that we can measure
it's not that which has mass or volume
not that which we can talk about subject
of a census or it or is that now none of
those that that's philosophy and of
course it's not what something is made
out of an object is that which has shape
that's the criterion okay for physics
and for science and what's you know and
so the devil's advocate or the skeptic
they come up and they say okay bill
smart aleck what is shape please define
shape because they want to be good
through this rigmarole where they say
well you need words to define words and
more words that they find those words
and so you know you'll never get to the
end of it that's that's their argument
that's that's the argument of the
skeptic of the guy who doesn't want to
deal with what he calls semantics
there's a problem the issue here is the
following we look at criteria okay and
these are different criteria for what an
object might be maybe you can come up
with a couple more okay but these are
the standard ones that people come up
with and I'm saying all we're doing is
comparing shape against them are we
gonna use C as a criterion are we gonna
use radius as a criterion are we gonna
use volume or mass what we're saying
here is that you have all these criteria
criteria which one are we going to use
to define what an object is for the
purposes of physics that's the issue we
don't need to know exactly what you mean
by mass or what we mean by touch or what
we mean by diameter
need to know exactly what these words
mean all we're saying is you know we're
gonna compare shape against and if you
don't know the difference between mass
and diameter between touch and subject
of a sentence well then you got a
problem because oh all we need to do is
compare all these and not mistake one
with the other you need to know that
size is not the same thing as as what
you can measure and what if something is
made out of it's not the same thing as
whether it can move so all we're doing
is choosing a criterion to define the
word object for the purposes of physics
so we don't need to know exactly what
shape is we don't need to have
SuperDuper acceleration for the word
shape that's the first argument the
second argument is much easier you don't
know what shape is very simple because
you know kindergartners can teach you
what shape is go to kindergarten show
them a block show my sphere made of the
same material and same color same
everything and you can ask the kid what
is the difference between these two and
you'll say the shape he doesn't know
what shape is but he knows okay that's
shape the difference we're doing a ball
that cube that's shape I mean you know
these people just piddled around what we
need to know is what criterion we're
going to use for the purposes of physics
okay and with that I'm gonna adjourn and
we're gonna meet you again on Sunday I'm
gonna continue with my criticism because
again this guy opened up a can of worms
Pandora's box evil running amok through
the scientific world now and I'm gonna
address all that evil I'm gonna look at
some of the other things that he said or
weren't said that kind of puts in doubt
a lot of where he's coming from you know
these people are really completely they
speak a different language they're doing
research in stuff that has no bearing on
anything and so these people are
completely misled they come out of
college with degrees they get a job you
know a teacher or maybe you know
research institution or some company
doing R&D or whatever and they don't
even know they don't have any bearings
they have no idea you know what they're
researching because they're doing it all
based on particles and this is simple
there are no such thing as particles and
every experiment debunks the particle
and also the way because there's no such
physical object as a wave so wave is not
even a candidate but a particle is
upended if it has shape but if it
doesn't have shape it's not a candidate
either if it's a vibrating field okay so
we'll see you on Sunday and we'll
continue with this line of questioning
okay we'll see you that bye-bye